speaking of crab legs annie letterman
told me she likes scrapbooks she told me
that you told her that you got really
fat but you look the same
what there's rumors in the industry that
bobby's getting wait
so annie letterman i thought it was her
someone said to me that
they're like oh you saw bobby was he fat
he said he's fat
yeah i texted with her and i said i'm
just getting really fat but this is some
a throwaway thing that i say to everyone
like you can say whatever because you're
not going to see them anyway and i don't
post [ __ ] anyway so i was just like
yeah i look like [ __ ] you know
ralphie mae now
but you are getting smaller because of
yoga um
kind of well you know how they say like
ninety percent of weight loss is in the
kitchen
um yeah really if you don't change that
part
like you don't change the outcome of
your body shape
that's true so basically yesterday so
you're
our yoga instructor kara yesterday
repeatedly said bobby
stop calling yourself fat stop calling
yourself fat
she's like you know if you're if you're
happy in the weight that you're in you
feel strong in the weight that you're
right you're happy in your weight clap
your hands
but then you're happy in your way clap
your hands fat fat
but then she was like but lay off the
pizzas that's what she said that's what
i said
gold belly stop eating pizzas every day
yes and i took that as an offense is it
a private yoga or a big group
it's private she does both oh you should
do it
we should do i think we've not invited
you before and well it was an informal
invite but we we should do it we don't
want to crash yours
you're not crashing it you just don't
zoom you could do it with us
wow and yesterday i'm gonna say number
one i've never had an other
i've never had i don't know what other
yoga teachers are like
but this i call her my master and um
she's my master and she um
her name is kara out of hawaii check her
out she um
she really worked me less yesterday i it
was the heart
first of all for you for those of you
this is who i was before yoga
yoga that's just a bunch of stretching
that's not a real exercise you know
like anyone that would do yoga would be
like oh yeah yeah
i also walk you know i mean like that's
how the level of
i thought that it was just like walking
or lifting your arm
right ooh yoga hard
right just licking your arms like that
right right i don't know why i'm doing
this you've been doing that a lot
you're like air traffic
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
why when you're happy with your weight
clap your hands
fat fat wait so but what would you say
about yoga now before you said
oh no so i'm gonna get into it oh it is
um
is the most difficult thing i've ever
done in my life i've been
into a lot of tragic situations in my
life a lot of physical exertion
you have i've been beat up yeah i've
been uh
you know i used to have this trainer you
know because abby thought
one time that i was going to be like an
action star a manager
so she's like i know this guy you know
he's the best trainer in the world
this a tall a muscular black guy
and he used to come to my house and he
used to [ __ ]
you're not done and i'm on the treadmill
you're not done
you would yell you're not done and i go
i'm dying
and then like if i would stop you would
grab me put me back on the truck
you're not doing you know and i was so
hard this is
way worse there's no way that's possible
oh yeah
dude okay what i love about yoga is this
she's like you'll be in a position right
what is that position
you'll be on a you'll be on your leg
like this
one leg and you're lifting up like this
i'm just getting making it
up right and she's i'm like it burns
right and then
well because you haven't you know use
certain muscles
there before right like you know some of
us have built up that muscle
right but because it burns because you
haven't you
and in my mind i'm like when would i
ever be in this position
how could i work on this i would have to
be
am i kicking if i was a soccer player
like this maybe this
right well that's really good babe right
flexible
right but when would you ever that's why
this is petrified
because i'm never in this position so
it's very difficult
you know um have you done yoga i have
there's a youtube
yoga that i do yoga with cassandra but
hers is
[ __ ] hers is mostly stretching
so i like stretching yoga i don't like
working yoga
can you please do yoga you and dave too
yeah that
he would do it yeah it'd be i would just
want to see
him do it well he doesn't want that he's
so he doesn't want to be seen
he can just be off i feel like i'm at a
position or a point with david that he
should be able to
allow me to see him tell him that i
think we're at at that point
i yeah i'm definitely open to
starting that conversation he's really
he that's like his worst fear though is
people watching him try to exercise like
he
the thought of like a workout class it's
just like the
that's his worst fear i would i would
and he could be doing it perfectly i
don't know why
because he whenever i see david it makes
me want to laugh
yeah he's funny he's just a funny joyful
you know
bundle of joy and um i just know that if
i saw him do yoga
that i would probably burst into
laughter
i wouldn't be able to stop myself so
maybe not do it okay yeah yeah
i don't want to hurt his feelings how
are you guys doing quarantining like do
you guys hate each other do you love do
you spend time together
i'm just curious from other couples like
what's the vibe